we know that two people and have been  injured we believe they received stab  wounds one of them is seriously injured  and we know that somebody was shot by  armed police and that that gentleman has  now died  eyewitnesses throughout the afternoon  have been telling us different things  it's hard to sometimes establish exactly  which things are definitely true it's  it's sometimes difficult too confusing  and you hear slightly contradictory  things but one of the things that many  of them have said or many of them have  commented on is the sheer speed with it  with which police arrived on the scene  one gentleman I spoke to earlier said he  saw an altercation between two people  didn't think much of it at first because  such altercation is not incredibly  unusual in this part of London but  they're saying that police were there  what felt almost instantly and to him  and that's something that a number of  people have said